hey Vsauce Michael here earth only
contains 1066 people earth Texas the
only place on earth officially named
earth there are at least two places
named moon but the earth only has one
astronomical moon or does it from
September 2006 to June 2007 Earth had an
additional moon named 2006 RH 120
it's a near-earth asteroid that usually
orbits around the Sun but for 13 months
it fell into an orbit around our planet
and became another moon of Earth we can
call it that because technically a moon
is just a natural satellite something in
orbit around a planet that humans didn't
put there there's no official minimum
size requirement for moon status V moon
it's a moon Sputnik space junk the
International Space Station not moons
they are artificial satellites
astronomers believe that most of the
time Earth has additional moons these
newcomers don't always stick around that
long and they tend to only be about a
metre in diameter so we don't always
detect them and they could lessen
sensationally be called temporary
asteroid moons but the vagueness of the
word moon means that yes technically
earth usually has more than one oh and
Earth is booked in it I mean we are
moving through space incredibly quickly
a Lightyear is an almost unfathomable
distance to put into human terms
but our solar system orbits around the
center of the Milky Way at about 780
2,000 kilometers an hour which means
that from the perspective of the center
of our galaxy about every 1,300 years
earth travels an entire Lightyear in
other words the Great Pyramid of Giza
wasn't just built 4,500 years ago it was
also built almost three and a half
light-years away
big deal what's it all worth could we
assign a price to the entire planet to
earth itself
well Greg Laughlin an astrophysicist at
the University of California Santa Cruz
devised a beautiful equation for
assessing the value of exoplanets we
discover it considers their habitability
their ease of being studied and of
course how much money we've already
spent looking for them funny enough you
can solve for Earth and find out that
compared to what we've already spent
looking for exoplanets and what we know
about them
earth is worth about five quadrillion
dollars The History Channel famously
stuck to earth and rang up all of
Earth's resources like water lumber and
granite using the current market prices
they arrived at a total of seven
quadrillion dollars if you removed and
isolated all of the elements your body
contains and then sold them each at
market price you could fetch about two
thousand dollars reddit users shady
potato applied this map to earth if we
could mine the entire planet and
separate out all of its pure elements
and prices didn't change because of that
we could sell it all for 15.8 sex Tilian
dollars of course calculations like
these don't include every single
possible thing earth or any other planet
has to offer and they also don't
consider supply and demand if someone
here on earth or some extraterrestrial
group of planet shoppers had
quadrillions sex
Killians of dollars or the equivalent
amount of power now they would have the
option to shop in a much larger store
for crying out loud there are more than
10,000 asteroids right here near Earth
and just one of them 433 eros is
estimated to contain a half quintillion
dollars worth of platinum alone and by
weight even more iron so to be more
realistic instead of calculating Earth's
value on earth let's calculate its value
the Galactic marketplace or the
universal marketplace if you or some
hypothetical group of aliens shopping
for a planet could pick any planet in
the entire Milky Way galaxy
what about earth would make it worth
anything the Milky Way galaxy is
estimated to contain a supply of around
100 to 400 billion planets as far as
earth analogs go kepler space mission
data suggests there are probably 40
billion earth-sized planets orbiting
within habitable zones of stars in our
galaxy and within the observable
universe quadrillions so from a raw
materials and habitability standpoint
Earth probably isn't that rare but earth
does have some unique selling points for
one it's probably the only planet like
itself within at least 12 light years so
its location might be prime real estate
for an intergalactic rest stop or
eminent domain and secondly
statistically speaking life as we know
it might not be unique to earth but
there probably isn't life elsewhere that
formed exactly like it did here with
Jaguars palm trees and hairless bipeds
who made the same buildings and jokes
and art and music that we have these
might be the truest unique selling
points for Earth aliens wouldn't have to
understand or appreciate any of it if it
merely amused them it might be worth
purchasing as a sort of museum or Zoo at
the least of course interstellar planet
shoppers wouldn't have earth currency to
buy it with and space cash isn't worth
anything here but the technology it
would take for them to get to us would
likely be at least thousands of years
ahead of what we currently have so an
equitable trade might be say limited use
of earth in exchange for their knowledge
or full use or abuse of Earth in a
change for their knowledge and fair
relocation of all Earthlings to some
equally habitable exoplanet boy this
type of speculation is totally sci-fi
but you know what's not the next part of
establishing Earth's value demand
despite what earth has to offer despite
what makes it unique and despite
national Geographics list of 10 reasons
other life forms might want earth so far
we have received zero offers the Fermi
paradox formally phrases this puzzle
with so many friendly to life as we know
it planets out there many of which have
been around longer than even earth why
haven't we been visited by or heard from
intelligent life yet maybe earth and
it's intelligent life really are rare
and special or maybe earth is so typical
so unremarkable no other intelligent
advanced life forms could be bothered to
stop by but this raises another question
even if something came by what makes us
think it would make an offer why would
it consider our wishes at all in Star
Trek for the aliens wanted to talk to
whales and humans were just an awkward
third wheel when Thomas Jefferson made
the Louisiana Purchase he didn't ask say
squirrels and Nebraska for permission he
just did it and all of those squirrels
were suddenly in America without knowing
it for all we know that may have already
happened to us earth could be owned by
some larger interstellar landlord
furthermore this entire question rests
on an even more fundamental assumption
the assumption that other intelligent
life-forms share our concept of
ownership and the belief that physical
things can be bought and sold
amongst Earthlings human bartering is
pretty unique only we have developed
complicated socially agreed-upon norms
for the barter
goods the use of currency for goods or
the concept that you can own a piece of
Earth's surface sure animals can be
territorial but they haven't developed
that into a more rigorous expansive
sense of fair exchange and when it comes
to an individual only more things than
they could possibly hold or defend on
their own
well we humans have systems for that we
can teach some animals to use tokens as
currency to exchange for treats but left
on their own they don't incorporate
economic ideas into their regular social
lives at the most we observe animals
bartering amongst each other for
services but not goods why well they may
lack the cognitive ability required to
keep track of long term transactional
histories but they also lack two other
extremely important things communication
and enforcement services like grooming
are difficult to steal so animals can
easily trade them but without a language
to facilitate snitching nonhumans can't
easily report thefts or devise systems
for reporting and punishing violations
animals create some pretty beautiful
things Bower bird nests puffer fish
circles termite mounds or the dramatic
costumes decorator crabs fashioned out
of sea floor debris but ownership and
the right to buy or sell what you make
is only as useful as the power you have
to enforce it and if you don't have
enough Tower someone or something else
will make decisions for you for instance
we have decided that animals don't own
the selfless
three years ago in Indonesia a monkey
stole photojournalist David Slater's
camera she later retrieved the camera
and found that the monkey had snapped
these fantastic images Slater maintained
that he should receive royalties from
people who reproduce the images like
Wikimedia but US federal regulators
recently ruled that since a nonhuman
animal created these photos they're
officially in the public domain they
belong to all of us the same goes for
selfies taken by elephants or lambs or
Asian short clawed otters named Moosa
and it's not just selfies at play here
the same goes for paintings made by
chimpanzees or dog artists so maybe
earth is worth quadrillions or sex
trillions of dollars maybe it's worth
wrenching in exchange for technological
know-how but the mere fact that we can
conceive of ourselves selling our own
planet is pretty incredible I mean we
don't have a deed to Planet Earth we
really only own it via Finders Keepers
but we didn't stumble upon earth like a
hermit crab in its shell we really just
emerged from it we didn't build earth if
anything it's selective pressures built
us does that mean Earth is sort of like
does that mean us selling earth would be
the same as a child selling his or her
parents well not really because we
aren't here for the purpose of leading
and now it is to be born honestly the
most fitting metaphor might be not that
we are Earth's owners or children or one
in the same with it but rather that we
are Earth's first willful effluvia
in the context of the human body the
flue via our little emissions of things
built up within they often make us
giggle and can be gross and isn't that
what we are a sometimes messy stinky
presence that has built up within and
will one day in evitable
and to an extent already have discharged
out into space I guess what I'm saying
is that putting a price tag on Earth is
all speculation we don't know if we will
ever be Earth's sales person but what we
do know is that we are Earth's first
fart and as always thanks for watching
[Music]